je suis en train de caresser une très
bizarre vous verrez comment le crâne
avec une carapace à moitié mort comme un
crack qu'il avait lui même et lisse
[Musique]
après 17 années de fonctionnement et
près de quatre millions de visiteurs
nous avions souci de leur fond ce
parcours tout en gardant une part de
l'adn de l'acide à merck a toujours été
laventure des hommes sous la mer mais en
y intégrant d'autres domaines d'autres
compétences d'autres aspects par rapport
à la manière dont les hommes se sont
emparés de l'océan depuis 17 ans matière
de recherche en matière de découverte
donc il fallait actualisé puis aussi
apporter à travers les outils numériques
multimédias des notions
d'expérimentation et d'interactivité
c'est laisser l'esprit c'est
impressionnant ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'être elle marche sur le sol ou alors
des fois elle se met à nager très très
maladroite mais sur le dos et c'est là
on voit que vraiment très très
impressionnant comme busquets fc des
bestioles qui vivent naturellement dans
des zones peu profondes à la plage comme
le golfe du mexique par exemple et maman
ils sont classés vulnérables par lycée
avec l'union internationale de la
conservation de la nature mais c'est une
des seules qui a un intérêt très
important au niveau biomédicale est ce
qu'on fait est là ensemble très très
précieux ce qu'elle permet de détecter
la présence de certaines bactéries dans
le sang ceux des bactéries qu'on appelle
à gram négatif il par exemple on à la
salmonelle ou escherichia coli fait qu
limule tout temps que les hommes
pensaient qu'elle servait à rien on l'a
broyé pour en faire de l'engrais vert
elle n'avait aucune utilité jusqu'au
jour où des scientifiques découvrent que
son sang bleu son sens
extraordinairement chargeant qui veut
avoir une utilisation une utilité dans
le monde de la pharmacopée de la
pharmacie voir même puisqu'il sert
aujourd'hui d'asepsie d'outils
chirurgicaux de détection etc
et là d'un seul coup c'est à nîmes
athisien protégé qui lui est utile et
qui est même un emblème c'est animal de
400 millions d'années qu'on ne
connaissait pas un jour on découvre
qu'il est extraordinairement utile pour
l'avenir des hommes et c'est ça qui est
intéressant
[Musique]
à défaut
je tenais dans ce parcours à ce qu'il y
ait un lieu emblématique dédié à jules
verne
nous l'avons créé ce salon jules verne
autour de la grande faille de 12 mètres
de haut comme j'irai dans le nautilus
tss ce monde ouvert vers le sait en quoi
l'immensité ce qui est assez surprenant
de la part de jules verne et c'est là
c'est un des plus grands visionnaires
mois que j'ai pu dont j'ai pu parcourir
les oiseaux c'est que cet homme bien
avant tous avaient imaginé le monde dans
lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui parce que
imaginait nautilus et le pote soumare à
l'époque appréhender ce monde sous marin
sans jamais avoir été sous l'eau et
derrière ça développer une telle vision
une telle poésie une telle imagination
que ça déclenche derrière
des envies et des vocations
[Musique]
où
s'ensuivront des années mais si vous du
dernier siège aussi ça c'est un projet
un projet un peu fou ou havre il ya
universités ou des master 1 master 2 des
jeunes se ce travail sur la biochimie la
micro chimie pour appréhender justement
et créer ces c'est parfait en termes de
molécules la formule chimique est trouvé
et que avec une société qui est
spécialisé dans la région lyonnaise dans
ce domaine là on intègre ces molécules
et ses produits dans des petites billes
que l'on a mis dans une armoire à odeurs
et le jeu c'est de reconnaître ce parfum
quand on parle du ressenti de l'émotion
on est souvent sur le hawzi la beauté
des images mais aussi la force des des
textes la force d'un d'un récit temps y
voilà mais il ya aussi pourquoi pas le
d'oran et c'est comme ça que ce projet
est arrivé
[Musique]
où
à regarder je trouve ça c'est chouette
mais choisir n'en bouge dans
l'infiniment petit donc en fait c'est
une caméra qui filme ce qu'il ya dans
l'aquarium clip a été gelée goutte d'eau
pour commencer votre voyage dans le
monde extraordinaire du plancton
là c'est john qui nous explique en
fonction de votre voyage au curling
imaginez c'est que j'aime bien parler
par déçu c'est un peu comme si pendant
d'étrangers eh bien je couds c'est comme
si c'était une coupe de la comen
derrière une prenait et zuma donc et du
coup on va regarder le plancton ans et
hadass et goudé parle bien de laisser le
hasard guider votre bruyneel explorer
les goûts et ouvrez les yeux sur la
visible par exemple on peut aller voir
un psy fono for a year des mois semble
les siphonophore c'est du plancton
animal il s'équilibre grâce à son
flotteur qui situé en haut et ses
cloches natatoire qui sont au milieu
c'est un peu le muguet de l'océan
[Musique]
où
là c'est un truc absolument génial
beaucoup va sous l'océan et on voit il
volcan regardez-moi ça
voyez ça
ça c'est des fans qui se crée du coup
la lave qui en sort en fait ça ce qu'on
appelle une dorsale océanique
c'est à dire que ces limites de plaques
tectoniques et entre temps il ya la lave
qui sort et du coup ça crée de la
matière en fait sacrer le plancher
océanique et c'est ça qui entretient
tout le mouvement terrestre des plaques
qui se créent par là et qui
disparaissent par là bas qui va plonger
sous sous la plaque l'autre plaque quoi
et là de la même manière ils ont
modélisé ce qu'on appelle des fumeurs
noirs ou des fumeurs et blanc ça dépend
c'est des sources hydrothermales qui
sont au fond de l'océan
certains scientifiques pensent que la
vie serait peut être apparu dans ces
zones là
[Musique]
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que comme de nombreux scientifiques et
de plus en plus c'est l'océan qui
assurera demain ou pas l'avenir
l'humanité elle est là la clé de de
cette exposition c'est est ce que les
hommes seront suffisamment sage pour que
le séant
au sein duquel on peut trouver les
médicaments de demain la chimie verte
l'alimentation l'énergie bref est ce que
les hommes seront suffisamment sage pour
que les menaces et et l'économie
intensive ne viennent pas perturber tout
cela donc voilà je n'ai pas fait exprès
[Musique]